hey pads you're smiling but I know
you're scared you haven't seen your
parents for half of your young life and
you're 5 you've already crossed
continents by yourself coming to America
to rejoin mom and make a new life here
don't worry you'll make it
you will get to college in spite of a
car wreck that leaves your body badly
broken and scarred freshman year you'll
be told you don't belong because after
months of being together your first real
boyfriend tells you his parents won't
approve of you you'll be devastated
it's his failing not yours you'll find
your way to Europe for the first time
you'll feel that being other is okay a
good thing even you'll see that brown is
beautiful scars and all back in America
there are many brown and black faces yet
you'll always feel like an outsider
looking in for years you'll try to fit
into the standards others set for you
because you want to belong belonging or
finding some Haven this will be the
theme of your life girl you'll be a
nomad and while this may feel like exile
it'll gain you the knowledge for your
life's work you'll seek shelter girl in
the most unlikely places
until you realize that the best roof
over your head is the one you build with
your own convictions your voice it won't
be heard by those who are supposed to
love and protect you at age 7 you'll be
molested you will use words to call it
out but you'll think those words don't
matter because life will go on as if
nothing happened
the sovereignty of your body will be
violated again
you will be raped at sixteen but by then
you'll be silenced into submission and
it'll take you decades to find your
voice but you you bury all that
somewhere deep you'll chisel a life for
yourself out of thin air and carry on as
if nothing ever happened you're
resilient though I know you're hurting
inside
just like your mother before you but
watching her you learn a lot for comfort
you will cook it comes really easily to
you and the kitchen has always been your
happy place in fact you don't know it
yet but your actual career will be about
tasting the world you'll write books
about food and how to be wholly
nourished hi I Padma Lakshmi and welcome
to my corner of melting pot you'll have
various TV shows all over the world
and one show called Top Chef Top Chef is
back the competition that shows what
really goes on behind the kitchen door
will change the way Americans think
about food this show will be a success
the three of you had our least favorite
dishes and you realize along the way you
are a value Adrian please pack your
knives and go
pads you won't just survive you'll
flourish but there are some serious
bumps in the road womanhood comes with a
handicap you won't understand the
uterine disorder endometriosis affects
every aspect of your life but you meet a
doctor and he saves you
he'll encourage you to use your words
and together you'll start a women's
health foundation changing the way the
illness is known globally when the pain
has finally receded you begin to
understand your voice matters life has a
plan for you one day a songbird will
flutter in your belly and life begins in
you you'll be a mom and your heart will
burst with a happiness that you've never
known or even thought possible you'll
see that this is the belonging that
you've always searched for your whole
life you will finally know peace you
will finally exhale you'll have many
lives that are one and though the
journey feels long it's really just
begun everything will be alright
you